if you didn't hear over the weekend
Equifax had a major security breach that
we found out about over the weekend the
financial information of a hundred and
forty three million customers could have
been stolen and I was one of those
customers I've not personally done
proactive business with Equifax so how
could this be
well Equifax is one of the three major
US credit bureaus so there's TransUnion
there's Experian and then there's
Equifax and they manage credit scores
credit reporting credit monitoring they
have your social security number they
have credit card data on endless numbers
of Americans and intruders were able to
access names Social Security numbers
birth dates addresses and driver's
license numbers including credit card
numbers for hundreds of thousands of
consumers as well how did I find out
that I was affected well I went to
Equifax security 2017 dot-com I put in
my last name and I put in the last six
digits of my social security number now
there are reports saying wait you should
even be careful with that website
because the security certificate for
that website hasn't been installed
correctly and is itself vulnerable to an
attack in any case I did it and maybe I
will end up regretting that I don't
think so though I think that the
information I put in is is okay not that
I have any reason to trust Equifax right
and I got the following image which
we're putting up on the screen for
people to see indicating that based on
the information provided we believe that
your personal information may have been
impacted by this incident there were
also some reports that no matter what
you put in on that website it will tell
you that you might have been impacted
but I tried putting in just some bogus
info and it said that it was not
impacted so it does appear as though
it's somewhat reliable I don't know yeah
it does seem a little bit sketchy that
they say it may have been impacted
because I guess anyone may have been
impacted but then why have this form to
begin with apparently may have been
impacted actually does mean something
but exactly what is sort of hard to know
you did it Pat and it said your
information also may have been said yeah
so first things first right initially
Equifax was saying that if on that
website you enroll in their trusted ID
premier service which I guess they're
offering people for free as a make good
that it would preclude your right to
participate in a future class action
lawsuit against Equifax that's been
clarified okay both Equifax and the New
York Attorney General indicated that's
not the case you can check your
information if you want to sign up for
that service you can and it's not going
to prevent you from being party to a
future class action lawsuit against
Equifax which by the way at least one
has already been filed you can decide
for yourself about that what I did is
number one I went to get my free annual
credit report I went to
annualcreditreport.com the breach was
actually uncovered by Equifax more than
a month ago so it's possible that if
your information was stolen and that if
someone was planning to use your
identity to apply for credit or whatever
that it might have already been done so
I looked at my credit report for free
annual credit report.com thankfully
knock on lucite so far so good as far as
my information being used to open up
credit accounts or whatever else next
what you might want to look at is filing
a 90 day fraud alert on your credit okay
this does not freeze your credit a
credit freeze is something else a fraud
alert means you're concerned about
identity theft as far as you know based
on what you saw on your credit report
your identity has not been stolen or
used surreptitiously so far and what the
fraud alert will do is it will allow you
to apply for credit what will happen is
before approving credit under your
social security number the lender will
have to contact you first for the next
90 days and you can do this with any of
the three credit bureaus I mentioned it
will be communicated and activated
across all three credit bureaus now in
the meantime as far as those lawsuits a
class action lawsuit against Equifax has
already been filed there's a team of
lawyers including former Georgia
governor Roy Barnes who has filed a
class action lawsuit against Equifax in
US District Court in Atlanta there's
been a number of individual lawsuits
already been filed the Atlanta lawsuit
is seeking statutory damages under the
FCRA
and as well as state statutes so we will
see what happens this is a major major
cyber security breach maybe I'll end up
connect collecting my $72 as
a party to this class action lawsuit
I've actually been party I used to have
a Honda Civic Hybrid years ago yeah and
they overstated the gas mileage on the
window sticker and so I was able I was
in tight my share was $100 based on the
average person's driving how much I
ended up paying extra in gas based on
the gas mileage that they promised very
often these class-action lawsuits by and
large benefit attorneys but hey you know
I think you and I both pad could
potentially participate in that lawsuit
I think so I think so and you know maybe
this is one of the benefits of the
Consumer Protection Bureau putting
forward by Elizabeth Warren oh yeah no
we don't need regulation there's a
there's an incentive for every private
company to regulate themselves and if we
just allowed the total free market to
take over nothing bad would ever happen
and if it did the market would be
completely self-correcting and all of
these companies who have endless tens of
millions or billions of dollars worth of
your financial information they would
just go out of business because oh wait
no they wouldn't actually we do need
financial protection if it happens to
Equifax and can happen to the other two
credit bureaus yeah but people may go to
them and it happens for them too what a
lot of people also don't get is those
three credit bureaus there's a reason
why if you file a fraud alert with one
it applies across all three it's because
they're completely interconnected and a
lot of them have the exact same data so
that this is major and will continue
following the lawsuits and I'll let you
know if my identity ultimately is used
for the purposes of evil as opposed to
good I'm on reddit at des Pakman show is
on I'm sorry I'm on Twitter at des
Pakman the show is also on reddit at
david pakman.com slash reddit today's
program sponsored in part by taga dabbe
the hosting specialist whether you need
dedicated server solutions Virtual
Private servers cloud server options
custom server solutions colocation
services whatever you need for your
business or project taga dab and their
expert hosting specialists and support
will set you up with what works for your
business or project and their hosting
services support a really wide range of
customers and businesses around the
world including bloggers tech startups
fine
Anne Shiell traders gamers web
developers and more you can use the code
TDPS 20 to get a 20 british pound credit
towards cloud server options at signup
tag adapt calm /td PS with that you can
try out their services and save 20
British pounds about 23 24 US dollars
you use the code TDPS 20 at sign up ta
ga da b.com /t dps check it out